[Applause]
46 points for Jimmy Butler
why not
why not Jimmy Butler Butler's got 49
points
14 in the fourth quarter Yana's Drive
spins fires no
thank you
Butler
[Applause]
shot clock in three Butler problems
it's a two-point game it's embiid saving
it Matt Crossing mid Court in the corner
for the lead Harris
I wish
in a Thicket of Defenders no loose
diving position
[Applause]
s
along with Cedric are their best free
throw shooters Clark in his street
Jackie
frozen leaves
timeout Virginia
did we just see what we think we just
saw wow
somebody getting ready to set a screen
Harden Works around it to watch the
defense report
s of two seconds game clock in shot
clock pardon sizing up
[Music]
harford's got 45. came out Boston
[Applause]
2.6 her lead well they got the switch
they wanted Al Horford guarding James
Harden
Steph Curry
has hit the line he has not missed this
year
[Applause]
Kevin I'm so sorry he was 22 or 22. I'm
not a dealer in Superstition look at
stuff look at stuff look at stuff that's
right he knows exactly what we're
talking about
thank you Mr Stevens It's retreat by
Bridges plenty of time on the shot clock
Kenny Smith three
rebound O'Neal keeping it alive the fake
by Tim but he went behind his back
flushed the ball playing Twister on the
floor
[Applause]
wow welcome to the NBA Playoffs it goes
to dinwiddy
embiid rejected by embiid with the
whistle
To None eight seconds and down by three
three
what happened there
so the best defenders on the bench
Campbell outside blaming for the lead
we've also dominated the offensive blast
chances are you'll get more than one
opportunity
Here Comes Campbell the other way
stripped to the ball follow UCLA
against Edwards the switch on defense
now on Prince LeBron takes it in kicks
it out Schroeder
[Applause]
full involved
it's off the small room for the seventh
game
[Applause]
but the buzzer sounded the light was on
it'll be reviewed
I don't think he got that in time great
effort by Derek white and didn't I say
you have they're saying on the floor
they're counting it you have to protect
the offensive rebound oh he got rid of
it
the Celtics are going to win there's a
game seven back in Boston early on the
floor is good back to get the plays
under review six foot points for Bane in
the now oh no
Brooks by Green Brooks what happened in
oh and they're talking they're
discussing the podcast hey both of them
kept their cool
said I uh Jared he said I'm not
subscribing to your podcast but I heard
what you said that jokic is clearly in
the lead for his third straight MVP
award this year he's been incredible and
very efficient
flying is Jeff Green he's too old to do
that oh my goodness
hammering at home nine and three at home
oh look at that
what did we just see there my goodness
it's a circus inside this building
tonight six of nine on threes for Hardin
needs to run exploding
picked up by Tillman we are seeing I am
telling you this is Elite listen to me
people Elite level Rim protection
Universe cannot believe what you're
saying oh my God
whoa this is
65-6 of 69. you know you know I'm giving
you the death stare right now right
people at home know what they were right
but you had to announce it but look at
if he misses they get chicken nuggets
here do I understand that correctly
I won chicken nuggets are saying give me
chicken another time
Point yeah
oh it's hard to to know intent
push it out Tatum switch the defense
Robert Williams
wow and that ball was deflected Here
Comes Randall that number Randall with
the spin outside Brunson in the corner
three hard
RJ Barrett sticks one one point lead for
the Knicks
he's had the big game he'll try to slash
inside one second to shoot
good oh what a shot